Did you know this?
In Hazbin Hotel in episode 2
Radio killed the Video Star,
we see Vox using his mind control powers
on the general population of Hal.
This is most likely how he controls people
divide technology.
But this power
and is regular formed as it work on Valentino.
When Valentinos complain about edgel dust leaving,
Vox tries to cool him down with his mind control powers.
This doesn't work initially
Fox and has to turn up his brightness on a screen
to make it work for Valentino due to him being a moth.
What are you doing, Val?
You're not going over there!
That slippery twink is going to remember who owns him!
I'm gonna fuck everyone in that rancid shithole,
I swear to god!
Was there any other cool details about boxes?
If that was his powers?
Leave a comment down below.